we got to ask about one of your iconic
projects wicked is getting that movie
made cynthia rivo ariana grande how do
you feel about that i feel great about
both choices obviously cynthia i'm
in complete adoration of i've known
ariana grande since she was 10. so
ariana
i'm very very proud of you she knows we
talk every day i love you baby girl and
it's an honor and a pleasure to pass the
wand and the crown to you
you talk every day i love you oh yeah oh
yeah
is she kind of are you advising her or
counseling her on at all i'm the mentor
but i'm also the mentee because i'm
learning from her as well
well i mean while i have you got to pick
your brain what's one piece of advice or
counsel you give someone on playing this
incredible part in wicked i told her not
to not to think about me to find our own
glinda
we talk about it we talk about it and we
talk about life a lot
just life just like yeah okay well now i
want to ask you for life advice
i'm not i'm no good i can preach all
right but sometimes i don't take my own
lesson um will we see you make a cameo
haven't been asked but you never know i
think i'd be great on the yellow brick
road somewhere
and so and dina menzel agrees okay both
of you yeah nominee how you feeling i'm
feeling pretty nominated
i think is this your first one at
critics choice i think i've been no
actually i've never been nominated
before we're breaking news i have
presented though
you know what as long as you're not
resenting um we're here
and you're nominated and i mean look
it's just such a fun moment when you get
to have your art recognized how does it
feel for this show to be recognized i
stand for the entire cast and crew of
schmidun we are so proud of what we did
we did a love letter to broadway and
poked fun at it with love and i'm just
happy i'm happy that it was recognized
by the way you got big congrats news
engaged right yes engaged
where is this gentleman tonight okay he
was going to be here and he doesn't have
cover but he is sick and out of respect
for everybody he's like i'm not going to
spread it
well we love that decision
how is wedding planning going have you
made progress i just heard white noise
and weddings somewhere in there i'm
letting my mom and the planner do it i'm
just going to show up folks
i'm going to take a page right out of
your run away bride twice got to focus
towards my bro my groom my groom and
head that way
do you know anything big small
destination local
not allowed to say or i'll get in
trouble apparently but i know it's sing
and i'm kevin okay
[Music]
you